Hey guys, summer's here and it's my favorite time of year.
I love to entertain in the summer 'cause the days are hot and the nights are warm,...
...and you can have people hanging out at your house super late into the night.
I've put together a really simple menu that's great for entertaining.
You're using your grill, lots of fresh herbs,...
...and it's gonna be your guests' best meal of the summer.
We're gonna kick things off with my Paloma cocktail,...
...a refreshing drink that comes together in minutes.
Then, I'll show you how to make my delicious herb-marinated feta,...
...the perfect first course to set the summer mood.
Then, for our main course, it's grilled skirt steak with a chimichurri sauce,...
...a classic summertime flavor.
And for our side dish, a summery watermelon salad with cucumber, lime and basil.
And for dessert, it's plum clafoutis with amaretto whipped cream and toasted almonds.